all right The Witcher yes I've seen the
requests and stuff takes time right so
the Witcher is a series on Netflix that
is based off of The Witcher books which
the games are also based off of but as I
understand this series is based off of
the books not necessarily the game and
it's this medieval world with magic and
warring kingdoms basically hitting at
the time they're like I have people
totally need they need that Game of
Thrones fix and there's no game of
Thrones the fact they've needed a game
of Thrones fix since before Game of
Thrones actually hit and did it for
being honest so it's a good time for The
Witcher and the meat and bones like the
heart of the series for me it's the
character Jarrell's he's a Witcher which
I don't know much about witchers as I
understand their kind of magical mutant
people that people actually don't really
like and there's not a lot of them
anymore I say from what I understand
because all right hold on I don't know I
don't know if leather blocks pitchforks
I got a got to protect myself okay I
can't believe I'm gonna say this I think
I've said it in other videos but this is
what your BAE
I haven't played The Witcher games put
the keyboard down typing hateful
comments I'll make you go blind so I
heard okay those lives oh yeah so I
haven't played The Witcher game so as
I'm watching The Witcher series I'm just
coming at it as a person who hey I like
a good series so let's watch The Witcher
don't know much about the lore I know of
Geralt and I know of yennefer because we
all know a few nifer so the main
character Geralt he has a really
interesting story but you don't see a
lot of his story it's just what you've
heard about I hope to see more of his
backstory as a series goes on before
right now is just a lot of intrigue with
him but man henry cavill bring some
charisma to that character at first I
was like it's that's a voice you're
doing he talks like this all the time I
don't know if it's because I know Henry
Cavill voice but at first I couldn't get
it out of my head that's like he's just
doing a voice right at any character who
sounds different than the actor they're
doing a voice but sometimes it just it
doesn't sound weird at first you just
kind of roll with it from the get-go
this one took me a couple episodes wait
a minute I'm he delivered one of these
moments mm-hmm
[ __ ] that was probably before that but
that's definitely that's a marker those
momma's your point you're like look
that's why he's epic it's actually this
series if I'm being honest took me an
episode or two to actually get into the
first episode I was like alright well
that episode happened but I heard the
show's good so I'll keep watching but at
a point just a charm of the whole series
in the end
trigger the characters it hooked me and
that's what does hook in fact the
character I loved most is definitely
yennefer no offense Henry you're still a
snack we all know that which I guess
also he's a big video game nerd and he's
a fan of The Witcher and that's why he
took the role that's amazing but
yennefer yennefer was great and heard
her tragedy is really the heart of the
show for me I guess there was a bit of
controversy surrounding yennefer
storyline I guess controversy might be a
strong term some people there were some
tweets I don't see that perspective
because I don't feel like this show was
ever saying yes she made the right call
she's perfectly happy yep she did it and
she's living her perfect life but she's
not she's actually quite miserable it's
a great cautionary tale about how beauty
and powers they're not everything
they're not going to bring you happiness
the more I think about it the more it's
just such a great lesson on looking
deeper into the person and the facade
people have or maybe not judging people
on how they look or the things they have
around them like you look at yennefer
and you'd be like she's gorgeous she's
powerful there's no way she's not the
happiest person ever and I feel like
that's a very applicable lesson to our
world so many times it's easy to see
someone whether it be online or an actor
or someone on Twitter and influencer an
Instagram model a youtuber whoever it's
easy to look at them and be like they
have the happiest life ever there's no
way if I had that life I would be the
happiest person alive but you don't
really know what you see if a person you
see because it's what that person has
chosen to show in a lot of cases with
most people famous or otherwise people
don't generally choose to show their
pain in the case of yennefer felt that
was really well executed but i felt she
made the show to be honest with you
she's my favorite and there's the
princess whose name is princess ciri
like the apple AI look at me honest with
you I thought she was good in the show
but her storyline always kind of made me
feel like I wasn't with the party right
now like imagine The Witcher is a party
and geralt and yennefer in there man
they're in the heart of it they're
dancing on the bars the music's going
and everyone's having a good time and
then you go outside for a break you know
maybe a drink of water maybe it's
getting too hot in there and you're
never away from the energy of the party
you're always in its orbit but you're no
longer in the heart of it the music's
still going but it's a little more
muffled alright
we'll go back in now the story says what
it felt like I felt like every time I
was with this character I wasn't with
the party of The Witcher she's an
important character she needs to find
Geralt and that's her arc is her just
looking for him still of the three
characters my least favorite of the arcs
I will say that about the stitching of
the show - it took me a little bit at
first I was like something seems off it
seems very jumpy and not connected then
it kind of dawned on me how they were
doing it where they were going and I was
okay and then it clicked I was fine
until then though it felt less than
smooth also some of the CGI there are a
couple of CGI monster scenes or animal
scenes wherever you want to call them
mythological creature scenes where
you're like that's a CGI monster all
right look I don't know if the show cost
but I felt like the CGI and the
mandalorian was much better than again
you have the the biggest most powerful
studio behind that show so I get it I
will say it could have done passage of
time better sometimes a lot of time
passes and at one point I was like okay
someone needs to say something and to
their credit they did there was a
throwaway line the person's like I
haven't seen you in this many years I
was like okay it's been that long but
even some other times especially with
yennefer she goes and talks to this
person who goes and talks to that person
I'm like I don't think those two
locations are near each other are so did
weeks passed months passed days did she
[ __ ] teleport I didn't really know a
show didn't tell me it's a passage of
time it's one of the show's flaws but in
the end I had a really great time with
The Witcher they did such a good job at
portraying likable and charismatic yet
flawed characters on screen I mean it's
not as though The Witcher Season 1 is
some Game of Thrones replacement for
Game of Thrones when it was at its peak
I mean keep those expectations in check
but in its own right it's a really
entertaining fantasy epic with really
charismatic characters and actors who
make themselves make it so like I can't
say that without saying it that way the
enjoyment I had with the witch are
vastly outweighed the flaws I'd like to
see where they go with it that's the
rule you know leave the audience wanting
more and by the end I was like I
definitely am salivating for more witch
all right so The Witcher on Netflix have
you seen it what did you think about it
have you played the games did you like
it have you not played the games did you
still like it how did it compare to the
games you know what I'm trying to ask
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you